son ya 29 muertos en el incendio de un
hospital en el sur de Pekín que ayer
dejó escenas tan impactantes como la de
un paciente descolgándose de la ventana
con una sábana atada la causa fue según
la televisión pública las chispas que
saltaron a la pintura inflamable durante
unas obras de reforma la oficina de
seguridad pública había tenido esta
mañana ya a 12 personas acusadas del
crimen de responsabilidad mayor en un
accidente entre ellos el director del
hospital y el jefe de la compañía
encargada de las reformas Y es que en
China no hay accidentes indetenidos
china está convencida de que los errores
se pagan y de que el castigo de unos
estimula la atención de todos estos 29
muertos convierten al incendio de ayer
en el peor en Pekín de Las dos últimas
décadas antes en China era más
habituales debido a la mala calidad de
los materiales y a la normativa laboral
laxa Ahora son escasos pero tienen
consecuencias por ejemplo el incendio en
un cibercafé en un Distrito
universitario de Pekín hace 20 años
obligó al gobierno a regular esos
locales normalmente lóbregos e
insalubres donde la juventud pequiniesa
pasaba las noches también después de un
incendio en una parriada al norte de
Pekín fue enviada a la piqueta para
derribar todas las infraviviendas y
legales en las que vivían los
inmigrantes de las provincias Rurales
del centro